[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
so I'm Ashwin I work at Microsoft and
I've really and I together we have been
contributing to Twitter Heron project
this is a streaming project and today we
will be talking about why do we need why
did we even get motivated about
elasticity in in streaming through a
system and then what something about
Heron how would implement it is in here
and so manual scaling is phase one if
any system wants to move potentially
towards the elasticity in the streaming
world then manual scaling could be the
phase one what we have implemented in
Harran and then Dalian which is work in
progress but it has it's about
algorithmic auto scaling and of real I
will talk about that later right so
generally speaking if I'm talking about
streaming I'm talking about streaming
application the pipeline most of the
applications have two kind of components
they have spouts and bowls if I use the
storm terminology and spouts usually
ingest records into the into the
application and Bowles will transform
the recall so there's ingestion of
records tuples so whenever you tweet
something that a spout would potentially
pull it from Casca queue or baby file
system and then injesting to the sister
in this in the pipeline for processing
and bolts would transform that maybe it
will augment it with location
information user information or those
kind of things so that is typically when
a user is creating an application he
would provide the code for the bolts and
the spouts and the arrows between those
two components are the streams which are
implemented by the stream processing
engine so that is where all the
semantics of or at least one guarantees
checkpointing and all the other routing
information that is what the system
implements so if I talked of spark
streaming if I talk about Heron or storm
then those arrows are what we are
talking about aunty bolts are either
implemented by the user or there will be
high-level dsl like maybe summing word
which will provide user with all this
out-of-the-box components for the
component for these instances
in reality when we have to handle large
scale large volume of tweets or records
send multiple deployments or multiple
instances of a particular component
running in the system for example I may
have 50 instances of the same Kafka
spout pulling from different buckets if
I may say and then ingesting into the
system so in reality but the user codes
it the first phase is designing or
developing the components and the second
phase is tuning those components and how
many instances of those components you
want and how many containers are on how
many physical nodes should be running
right so that is how typically in
streaming world people think about
deployment of streaming applications and
pipelines so if what was simple this is
done but no things become complex when
you talk of realized topologies for
example this is one of the topologies
which is generated by which is currently
running in production in Twitter and you
see like if I talk about you see there's
a cascading effect from one component to
the other if I increase the component
parallelism for cepes two then what
happens downstream how many instances
should I increase it may not be easy to
figure out that right if that is not
difficult than this more complex
topologies these are generated by high
level systems which are which inject
more and more complex operator logic
into the system so when I talk to
developers the first challenge I see is
it is very difficult to find out what is
the parallelism which you should do for
the topology how many instances should
it be running right anticipating
component parallelism just by looking at
the logical visual diagram of the
topology is very very hard
people spend lot of time large take the
time to market an application time to
take a to production it just increases
by weeks when you have these kinds of
complex topologies
the second thing we see is that in an
ideal world you have a constant load an
average thirty thirty three thousand
tuples per second coming into a system
but no that's not the real case when
people get up in the morning the load in
the system and significantly higher so
this is a real workload and what we see
is that around 6 a.m. when people get at
the start tweeting also all around and
then suddenly this lot of load in the
system and then there are not including
the spikes which come when this election
is flooding they're natural disasters so
a lot of things change and in when these
things happen and you ask a developer
what is going to be the parallelism it's
again a difficult question right so we
have talked about two two challenges
when I'm talking about two docking
developers and also like most of the
time when you think of those components
sometimes you develop those components
sometimes developers reuse it they
downloaded from github or some component
and it's very hard to find out for each
component what is the parallelism right
so if you download it from somewhere and
you have to make some code changes you
have to rebuild redeploy it it's going
to take more weeks more days every time
there is a small change required right
suppose you turn it in correctly what
will happen your support cost will go
obvious that the SLA which is desired
for the particular couple to move across
the system the stalls the pipeline will
be significantly higher than what was
expected so and the provisioning are
wrongly misconfigured topology totally
ruin see if all the effort which is gone
in developing the topology itself and
finally most of those applications these
days are running in shared environments
right you have yarn or aurora shared
clusters on which the topology is
running an external environment change
they could be an application which could
be hogging the network all together or
there could be Hardware degradation so
given all this what will you do what is
solution we available to the
administrators of the application power
provisioning right now origins are norm
this is what we see in production right
now that in some cases the over
provisioning is as much as 80% most of
the time 80% of the codes are not
utilized and who is happy the cloud
providers
they're very happy about it because
those challenges are very hard to solve
and because of which the default
solution is to over provision and it's
not efficient at all so what we see is
that this Co for elastic elastic scaling
here when s elasticity if the load is
increasing if there is a path this is a
way to increase the number of instances
increasing number of nodes which are
assigned to a pipeline or when there is
no load at night when there is some all
the people are sleeping at that time we
reduce the hardware assigned to the to
the application so there is this
different locks Co for reducing the
hardware cost the administrative cost
also could be reduced it is elasticity
because when you look at the runtime
performance of the topology and based on
that you can see whether you're meeting
there silly or not and if it is elastic
you can tune it automatically up and
down SLA stability all these are factors
which can improve if storm if here and
all these components were elastic in
nature so what is here and what we have
done is that we have introduced one of
the canceled we have implemented elastic
is inherent Heron if I may say it's tom
plus plus it's storm like it increment
it has it is compatible with the storm
API and it is a real-time distributed
fault order and stream forcing engine my
understanding is that in Twitter they
have replaced storm with head and all
the topologies all the tweets in
production today they go through the
storm to the Heron system right now and
last year this was open source and that
is where me and Aurilia we started
contributing to Heron
so Heron is fundamentally different from
storm the way it is it is designed for
cloud and shared environments every time
it the application is deployed it
borrows containers from the underlying
framework it could be on when you start
a yon application an application master
starts and it create more containers on
the yun cluster so there is a shared
cluster and based on how many
applications you have Karen and what is
the size of the application more and
more containers can can be allocated to
the topology so what this means is
unlike storm in which the storm cluster
is deployed first and then applications
are deployed on top of this storm
cluster which means that if the area
don't have any of application storm will
still keep occupying the resources in
Harran every time in applications deploy
resources acquired at that particular
point of time so there is isolation at
the topology level because it's running
in zone in phone application master or
in order container level and each and
every component which we talked about
earlier the instance of components is a
JVM process itself in storm it was each
each instance is a thread in the same in
one JVM because of which there could be
some sort of interference and the
isolation is not guaranteed
harren what we have seen is the system
over a distance in differently lower
than storm and or the is less than ten
percent compared to the user the time
spend in executing user code it
currently provides at least one set
Muslim antics back pressure is one of
the importance in Quadrant concepts
implement insta inherent what does that
is like if at any particular phase in
the application the pipeline the phase
is not able to execute the load then we
then be these routers which are stream
managers in this particular diagram they
are instructed not to ingest any more
tuples into the pipeline as a result the
type the pipeline is temporarily bring
to a pause state and because of which
the system is able to complete whatever
is in this in the in the pipeline right
now instead of crashing out of memory
and all those kind of errors and it has
a modular implementation because of a
lot of customizations can be done so
twitter implemented be or a scheduler
part of sharon and we implemented the
yarn part of we ported this on eon so
you can change the scheduler you can
change the way these containers are
located and the way these are the
instances are distributed in the system
so earlier we talked about that there
are components there are instances of
components and what happens is that when
I talk about the modularity also talks
about I don't think lost packing plant
which means that when you have 100
processes and those hundred processes
have to be distributed to say 20 worker
nodes so how do you pack them what kind
of locality information is required what
kind of based on the dag information a
lot of customizations can be done and
that is what a packing plan governs so
this is what we'll talk about later
again how does the whole you submission
work in Herrin so when a user submits a
topology on the client a packing plan is
created this packing plan essentially
tells Herrin which is a client library
that how many containers on the shared
cluster would be required it starts a
heron scheduler which could Excel be
running on the cluster outside the
cluster and the system will go ahead and
acquire the containers from the Herren
library will go and acquire the
containers subsequently in those
containers processes for each of the
instances of the each of the instance of
bowls or spouts will be started and
stream managers are the routers which
will route the data across the instances
so once the containers are located once
the process has started then the
internal printer the illustration of the
lab of the of the pipeline world starts
which means that the instance is
registered to stream manager followed by
stream managers registering with the
topology master this turns see topology
master that the topology is act is ready
to start processing data so the posi
master will instruct this tree managers
to start in ingesting data into the
streams and the stream managers will
start routing the data across different
instances
so this is a typical another
representation of the topology
management process you submit apology
you create a packing plan resources are
acquired topology connections are made
processes started and when the process
start user code will probably build a
state there which could be a machine
learning state which could be other key
value whatever state is required right
these four state steps are executed by
the Heron system which is like creating
the packing plant acquiring resources
installing the topology and starting the
topology and these two are the user
tasks squaring the code has to be
submitted and the state has to be built
right but this is where the real problem
starts early because these fourth four
steps are very very time-consuming if
I'm talking about the previous packing
plan we saw earlier we total had four
hundred containers approximately in
which there were sixteen hundred
processes if those particular every time
you have to acquire these many
containers and start these many process
takes it can take quite some time so
these are time consuming steps when
building state we are hitting a remote
service and you're reading the state
from there this is followed by
monitoring the state if there if the
topology is able to meet the SLA if it
is if there D if there is extra load in
the system and based on that the
administration could decide that no I
have to retune the topology currently
the solution is to kill the topology and
redeploy the topology what this means
all those steps which are time consuming
they have to be restarted essentially
this is where the the discourage all
these adminstrators are discouraged to
retune the topology and they always over
provision it and the hardware cost keeps
going up so what is the solution the
solution essentially is that instead of
killing this instance is killing all the
processes releasing all the continents
back to the resource manager if there
was a way to just do the Delta changes
for example if the topology has to move
from seven instances to eleven instances
in the example if it is possible to
retain all those processes and existing
containers and just add new containers
start new processes in the existing
space then the Delta application
really really fast right and that is
what we have tried to implement that
whenever a heron topologies restarted at
that time try to retain as much as
possible and this significantly makes
the deployment process faster so what
I'm saying is instead of killing the
topology installer Heron you added a
command called update topology which
will pause the topology temporarily so
that the all the instances new instances
could be allocated and then existing
instance I inform that there is a
topology change happening right now and
they can prepare themselves this is
followed by an pause and the regular
process starts so Z tuning becomes very
very fast this is the manual step which
we have implemented as of now and this
is this in minimally disruptive as were
talked about so instead of hours or tens
of minutes which was required here in
our experiments and in our experience we
have seen that in at 1 or 2 minutes most
of the updates are successful and
because we have continued the modularity
and this could be customized also based
on experience with behavioral
requirements still there is some work
required here we have not integrated
state management into a bit process
which means that some sort of user
informations required whenever a
topology state topology configuration is
changed and instead of instead of
flushing the cues automatically what we
do is we pause the topology and wait for
some time assuming that the stream
managers will route all the existing
tuples in the pipeline and they will be
processed also we could do a lot of
things automatically what I mean is like
we talked about this state earlier that
the topologies are a bit command is
issued this pause adding resources and
all that the responsibility of
monitoring the topology is with the user
right now you monitor it whether you are
able to meet this made the requirements
or not instance back pressure in the
system or not the system is what this
self aware that is back pressure it's in
the in the pipeline if that is the case
then this could be done automatically so
Heron can take care of monitoring the
application and it can issue the update
comment itself and that is what is
algorithm water scaling and
my clearly we'll talk about this yeah so
hi everyone
so as we basically described how we can
do manual updates in the topology how
can change the parallelism in a topology
manually so in the next part of the talk
I will describe how we can do it how can
we how we can have the system do this
automatically so so the idea is again
that hearing should automatically
identify variations in the incoming load
and react to them essentially retune the
topology on the fly so that the user
doesn't have to intervene and change the
perilous so to do that we build a
framework called dalian so dalian is
essentially a framework that sits on top
of Heron and other streaming engines
potentially and provides self-regulating
capabilities to them and I will describe
a bit later what I mean with that the
idea is that the dalian will take data
from here on and it will understand when
there is a problem and it will try to
retune the topology maybe scale up or
scale down resources so Dalian will be
open source in the near future maybe in
one or two months as part of the Heron
project yeah Dalian periodically observe
the state of the topology and determines
whether we need to scale up resources
scale up or down resources so as I said
essentially Dalian provides
self-regulating capabilities to
streaming systems so the first cover
bility that we want is to have a system
that self Tunes itself so as has been
said it is a time consuming process
potentially error-prone to tune the
topologies we've seen that in production
so the idea here is that the system
should take as input and SLO maybe a
throughput is lower latencies hello and
then automatically configure the knobs
and by nodes I mean the parallelism as
has been said or how many containers we
should deployed how much resources we
should assign to it ciarán instance and
so on secondly we want to provide
provide self-stabilizing capabilities so
the idea here is that streaming
applications are long running they might
run for weeks or even months another has
been said during
that satellites period of time we
observe reload variation so there could
be schedule flow variations for example
every morning we expect more to eat than
in the afternoon or even at schedule
there is a natural disaster there's some
Sammy then happen and all of a sudden we
have spike so the system should be able
to adjust to that essentially
reconfigure itself to a managed incoming
load and the sense of ability we want
the self-healing capability because
these applications are long-running we
observed during that time hardware or
software performance degradation I note
that this is different from failures
because failures are easy to detect when
an instance fails or a containers fail
fails we can detect right away in
restart but it's much harder to detect
when an instant runs slower than
expected on where all where a physical
note the hardware and slower than
expected so Dalian helps detecting these
issues and recover from them so Dalian
essentially executes policies so it's
politics has three phases so in the
first phase dialing collects metrics
from the system in this case here on and
tries to identify symptoms that can
potentially be know that there is a
problem in the system so for example if
we see back pressure in here as we
mentioned it means that some components
cannot really process the load as
expected and that the symptoms that
something might be wrong we don't know
exactly what it is but it's a symptom in
the next phase after collecting all the
symptoms Dalian performs diagnosis
generation so it collects all the
symptoms and try to I tries to identify
what is the cause of the symptoms so for
example if we see back pressure a course
could be that we haven't tuned the
parallelism correctly so we need to
scale up resources or another reason
could be that some instance is slow and
cannot process the load fast so it
causes back pressure all there is data
skew and some instances overloaded so
Dalian collects all the symptoms and
tries to identify what is the cause of
the symptom and then after collecting
all the diagnosis it tries to find
possible resolutions
there could be a space of potential
action so for example we might restart
an instance we might scale up or down
resources there are many options here
and at this phase we basically select
the action that seems more suitable for
solving the particular problem and we
execute the action so the architecture
of Dalian is shown in this figure so at
the bottom part of the figure you can
see here on essentially the picture is
very similar to what has been solved we
have the container we have the
containers the instance is the three
manager and then on top of that we have
Dalian which consists of three
components the first one is the Shelf
manager the Health Manager is
essentially a process that periodically
executes the policies the user defined
so we can have a policy for dynamic
resource allocation of resources a
policy for meeting a particular latency
SLO and so on so the Shelf manager
periodically executes the policy then
we'll have the action log that maintains
a list of actions taken by the policy
along with the timestamp and all that so
that we can debug and see what what's
happening in the system and then we also
have an action blacklist that
essentially captures with actions were
taken but didn't actually improve didn't
actually leads to the collect outcome so
for example we may have an action that
says I expect if I scale up resources to
meter through Buddhist hello but after
performing that we didn't meet the
support SLO so essentially Blackie's
action so that we don't repeat failed
actions again so as you see dialing
speak it has a pretty simple
architecture and it sits on top of the
streaming system so basically it
requires to api's from the system one is
a matrix API where it can collect
metrics from the system here and
provides the matrix manager process that
basically outputs matrix over time and I
alone exploit this matrix and it also
requires an API to perform changes in
the topology in disk in case of in the
case of hearing scheduler a performance
of the changes so basically if we want
to add container scale up or down
resources we go through the scheduler
component so let's see what is the auto
scaling policy
in Dalian so as I said there are three
phases in the first phase we collect the
gain matrix from here on and we try to
identify three symptoms the first
symptom is whether there is back
pressure in the system as I said before
this might might be know that there is a
problem in the system and it can
potentially so that we need to scale up
resources the second symptom is we
observe the packets at the queues of the
system so if the number of packets is
really large so the average queue size
is really large then that's an
indication that maybe some process is
running slower that the system cannot
keep up with a load and the third
symptom is basically we observe at a
given stage of the topology the
processing rate how many tablets are
output allowed put given to the output
queues for each component and we compare
so if there is some instance that has
much lower output rate than the similar
instances of the same state then that's
an indication that something is going
wrong with that state so after we
collect all the symptoms Valiant get
into the second phase it tries to
identify the reason for the symptoms so
one reason for a symptom could be
resource over-provisioning so
essentially we see that the packet the
average queue size is almost zero which
means that maybe we have provision too
many resources for the particular
topology and even reducing the resources
means that we can still meet our SLO
then it's anti provisioning so if there
is back pressure and we see that all
there is all the components of a
particular States cannot keep up with
the load then maybe that means we need
to increase the parallelism of that
particular state then we also perform
diagnosis for other symptoms for example
if there's a to screening system let's
say one instance receives more data than
the others in the same state that could
denote this Q or if some instances are
slower than their peers in the same
states that we can also detect based on
this matrix and then we go into the
third stage where after we collected the
diagnosis we have a list of potential
action so the actions here sorry the
actions here could be to scale down a
particular component a particular bolt
or to scale up a bolt or to somehow
resolve data skew made
changing your heart function or restart
slow instances in new containers and see
if if they will start improving better
and finally after picking up the
particular action we invoke the
resultant so with this policy we are
able to scale up and down resources and
note that we are able also to identify
so we don't blindly scale scale up
resources maybe the problem is somewhere
else maybe there's data skew or some
instances are running slow so we are
able to identify that so that we don't
unnecessarily increase the resources are
used by a topology so we have some
initial results this is a simple example
a simple topology where basically will
have the topology a steady state s1 and
we decrease the load of the topology by
20% so we sort of decreased by a small
factor just to test if dialogue is able
to understand that this thing has
happened and as you can see here Dalian
actually understood that and in scale
down resources twice so basically it
scale it we have two types of balls in
little in this topology there is a
problem with the figure so there are the
counter balls and the splitter ball
so we scaled down both encountered balls
and the splitter balls and as you can
see the throughput of the topology
remains the same which means that it was
a good decision to scale down we didn't
decrease performance so we reach steady
state as two and then after some time we
increase the load by 30% and with we try
again to see with we we expect to see
dolly on understanding that in scale up
resources which actually happens so
dialing scaled up resources four times
until it reaches steady states three
where basically we don't observe back
pressure and we have the maximum
throughput and here you can see
basically how resources change over time
based on Dyan with with a different
steady state s1 s2 and s3 so you can see
that over time it reduces or increases
the parallelism as needed another policy
that we can have is essentially how to
satisfy through potential also given so
the idea here is that we want to
eliminate the tuning faces especially
before getting the Duvall's into
production so what happens here is that
they use
submitted apology with pilot 1 at all
levels and the throughput is a low for
example I want to have 1 million tablets
per second out of the system so Diane
should help reconfigure the topology so
that you can meet distribute SLO so how
does that it automatically Tunes the
number of spouting balls so that the SLO
is met essentially this policy uses the
mechanism of the auto scaling policy but
we have implemented additional symptom
detectors diagnosis and resolve it and
here you can see some results so
basically we started with a topology
with spiral is one at time 0 and then
over we set the throughput to a little
more than 4 million tablets per second
and you can see the dial on essentially
increases the resource until you meet
that so here you can see we take some
time to actually meet that the reason is
that we had a constraint in the system
not to increase the resources more by
more than 4x at a time so because of
that we had extra steps but still this
time is reasonable for pre-production
phase where you basically try to tune
the topology it takes a days now here it
takes about 90 minutes no less than that
70 minutes so what our future plans
so first we want open-source dalian and
the auto scaling policy as part of the
hyrum project and then we want to use
dialing to enforce throughput and
latency SLO and tota tuned here and the
policies that we expect that to help a
lot the developers and then we want to
combine scale and scaling with stateful
stream processing so this is currently
under work we're working progress and we
have pull requests already for that
so here you can see how you can get
involved with Sharon and the vegetal
repository the tweet the Twitter account
so feel free to ask questions and also
find us after the talk to talk more
about Sharon so and with that I'll be
happy to take questions
this is being used by Twitter is this
being used by Microsoft at all I mean so
currently not not yet but we've been
working on that for one year so our lab
basic
he works a lot on open-source and this
is one of the projects we are actually
invested invest but it's not yet in
production okay